and to that point i remember like
the last email that i sent to freeman
dyson was like in his last birthday
he was really into number theory and
primes so what i did is i took like a
photo of him
a picture and then i turned that into
like um
a giant prime number so i converted the
picture into a bunch of one and eights
and then i i moved some numbers around
until it was
a prime um and then i sent him that
also the the visual like it still looked
like the picture
it's made up of a problem that's tricky
to do it's hard to do
it looks harder than it actually is so
the the way you do it is like you
convert the
darker regions into eights and the
lighter regions in ones
and then there's just keep flipping yeah
but there's like some primality tests
that are cheaper from a
computational standpoint yes but what it
tells you is is
it excludes numbers that are not prime
then you end up with a set of numbers
that you don't know if they are prime or
not
and then you run the full primality test
on that so you just have to keep
iterating on that
and it was it was it's it's funny
because when you got the picture it was
like how did you do that it was
super curious too and then we got into
the details and again this was it was
already 90 i think 92 or something
and that curiosity was still there um
so you could really see that in in some
of these scientists
you